you go to Genesis
25:20 it's talking
about Isaac being 40 years
old Isaac being 40 years
old when he married Rebecca pay
attention when Sarah died she was 127
years old okay now read with
me when Sarah
died when Sarah died Isaac was 37 but if
you're Genesis 25 it says Isaac was 40
years
old right when he was married to Rebecca
so if he was 37 when Sarah died why is
it he was 40 when he married Rebecca now
let's read the comment are you ready
let's read it from Rashi I gave you the
link let's post
it okay here it is pay attention because
obviously she was too slow to get it
guys please pay attention class has
begun okay notice it says 40 years old
40 years old so here is rashi's
commentary and he's talking
about Isaac being 40 years old why here
watch here Genesis 25:20 here you go
Genesis 25:20 now let's read context
here's the verse from kab.org Genesis
2520 Isaac was 40 years old when he took
Rebecca the daughter buul the aramean of
padanam the sister leban the Arman to
himself or wife so he's explaining why
is it that Isaac was 40 when he married
Rebecca when Sarah died when he was 37
so why that Gap understand he was 37
when Sarah died but he was 40 when he
married Rebecca three years right now
let's read the comment three years right
okay now let's read the comment here's
his comment quote remember when you
follow a god who's the greatest of all
deceivers you will lie and cheat and
deceive but if you follow the true God
then you will be a people of Truth May
we what practice what we preach 40 years
old for when Abraham came from Mount
Moray now this is Rashi he was informed
that re Rebecca has been born that's
years earlier Isaac was then 37 years
old for at that time Sarah died and from
the time that Isaac was born until The
Binding of
Isaac when Sarah died were 37 years so
you understand what he's saying long ago
when he went to sacrifice Isaac he heard
that Rebecca died so then he waits for
many years Sarah dies Isaac is Now
37 right and then Abraham sends Eleazar
to get him a wife from his father's
house okay for she was 9 years old when
Isaac was born and 127 years when she
died as it is
stated
above right 23 vers one the life of
Sarah was 127 years this makes Isaac 37
years old at that time Rebecca was born
so he's saying that 37 when Rebecca was
born all right that's his calculation he
waited for her until she would be fit
for merital relations three
years he's not saying he waited for her
to be three years old he waited three
years you understand he didn't say
Rebecca was three years old he's saying
Isaac waited how long three years cuz he
was 40 when he married her do you see it
didn't say Rebecca was three years old
it says he waited three
years clear even even Muhammad who
couldn't read could read that and
understand okay we got that you
understand what he just
said Isaac
waited he was 37 when Sarah died Isaac
waited for Rebecca to be mature for
marriage how long did he wait three
years it didn't say she was three years
old he waited three years which is why
he was 40 when he married her even
though Sarah died when he was 37 did
everyone get that now I'm going to give
you proof from Genesis 24 she's one
amazing three-year-old she is stronger
than Samson stronger than Aisha because
I'm going to show you what this
three-year-old was able to do are you
ready now let's go to Genesis 24 let me
get you the verses Genesis 24:
10 to 67 okay revised Standard Version
Catholic edition man if she was three
she was mightier than Samson and Aisha
mightier than David because she's one
powerful Hefty three-year-old now watch
watch Genesis 24:10 to 67 let's read
watch here you ready let's go let's read
it all right watch here guys tell me how
many three-year-olds you know that do
this here right here just read your
Bible brothers and sisters just read
your Bible one thing you're going to
learn in these sessions know your Bible
no context know the verses before and
after chapters before and after now pay
attention it is so embarrassing I'm
embarrassed for them that they would
humiliate themselves to this level to
justify a 54 year old man mounting a
nine-year-old here you go eleazer is
sent by Abraham to Abraham's father's
family to get Isaac a wife so he comes
then the servant eleazer took 10 of his
master's camels and departed taking all
sorts of choice gifts from his master
and he arose went to Mesopotamia to the
city of
nahor and he made the camels kneel down
outside the city by The Well of water at
the time of
evening the time when
women women go out to draw water who
women not little girls and he said oh
Lord God sovereign yahwah
of my master Abraham grant me success
today I pray thee and show steadfast
love to my master Abraham behold I'm
standing by the spring of water and the
daughters of men of the city are coming
out to draw water let the maiden so
here's a test God who do you want Isaac
to marry here's the test the one you
have for Isaac let her do this what's
the test let the maiden to whom I shall
say pray let down your jar that I may
drink and who shall say drink and and I
will water your camels let her be the
one whom thou Hast appointed for thy
servant Isaac by this I shall know by
this I shall know that thou H has shown
steadfast love to my master now watch
what an amazing three-year-old dude she
had more muscles than Arnold
Schwarzenegger she was more powerful
than Samson so here comes the
three-year-old Focus guys here comes the
three-year-old three-year-old Rebecca
man she's one Mighty woman before you
done speaking behold Rebecca who was
born to beul the son of milka the wife
of n Abraham's brother came out with her
water jar upon her shoulder damn that's
one strong three-year-old to carry a
water jar and fill it with water and put
the water jar on her shoulder and take
it back walking that distance man that's
one powerful three-year-old damn
W that's one amazing three-year-old old
man
damn hey any of you got those kind of
three-year-olds in your
house
huh okay now watch the test the maiden
was very fair to look upon a virgin whom
no man had known she went down to the
spring and filled her jar and came up so
she filled up the water jar put it on
her shoulder she's a three-y old she
probably had a doll in her other hand
because she had muscles on top of
muscles then the servant ran to meet her
and said pray give me a little water to
drink from your jar she said my drink my
Lord and she quickly let down her jar
upon her hand so three-year-old tooks
the jar puts it down when she had
finished giving him a drink she said I
will draw for your camels also until
they have done drinking so here goes the
three-year-old said hey you got camels
right and each camel needs gallons of
water so I am three years old but I am
Supergirl I put Superman as shame and
Samson I'm going to go and keep filling
the water jar with water to fully
satisfy not one camel but a bunch of
camels that need gallons of water to be
satisfied because I'm
Supergirl see how that
works that's one Mighty in fact guys if
you can go yeah Powerpuff girl can you
go on Google and put in how many gallons
of water does does a camel need to
drink because remember it's camels can
you confirm the greatest scholar ever
lived she Google how many gallons of
water does a camel need and she this
three-year-old while this grown man
ilaser is going to sit back and let a
three-year-old go back and forth getting
water to satisfy camels okay so she
quickly 10 gallons just what tongue huh
30 gallons in one sitting 30 gallons of
water 20
gallons and that's just one Cel yeah man
this is one Mighty three-year-old the
man gazed at her in silence you know why
he gazed at her in silence guys because
he's shocked like
damn What a Mighty three-year-old this
is Power Puff Girls
Supergirl hey you three-year-old come
here you can go back and forth and fill
up your jar with water to give to my
camels which takes at least 20 gallons
to 30 gallons satisfy one camel you can
do that damn girl any other
three-year-olds that strong can you even
like press me over your head and how
many reps can you do at the age of three
by pressing me damn you one Mighty
Girl so you see that's why he was
silent the man gazed at her in silence
to learn whether the Lord had prospered
his journey or not okay are we ready to
move on we got some more hold
on okay watch here it's a long one but
we got to put this nonsense to
bed put this nonsense to
bed watch here yeah that just tells you
the levels they will stoop when the
camels had done drinking camels the man
took a gold ring weighing a half a
shekele and two braces for arms weighing
10 Golds getting 10 gold shekel and said
tell me whose daughter you are you are
so notice she's there not accompanied by
her parents or her brother she's all
alone talking to a stranger at the age
of three three years old right is there
room in your father's house for usian
she said to him I am the daughter of
buul the son of Mila whom she bore to
nahor man pretty intelligent
three-year-old she knows all her history
she added we have both straw and
provender enough and room to Lodge in
the man bowed his head and worshiped the
Lord yahwah and said blessed be the Lord
yahwah the god of my master Abraham who
has not forsaken his steadfast love and
his faithfulness toward my master as for
me yahwah the Lord has led me in the way
to the house of my Master's Kinsmen okay
now
watch yep she was on growth hormone
brother she must be taking performance
Hing enhancing drugs yeah she was on
growth hormone she was ready for Miss
Olympia at
3 then the maiden ran now the
three-year-old's running three-year-old
after all day taking a jar of water
giving enough water for a flock of
camels she's still not tired at three so
God knows how many hours it took for her
to give enough water for the camels she
still has energy to run at Three she's
running see she was a
triathlete she was doing a triathlon she
was a triathlete dude this was the
triathlon
of Paden Aram she was training for the
Olympics the Paden Aram Olympic Games so
she's not running wow girl you ready to
take on all them athletes man that's
some powerful growth hormone girlfriend
best pre-workout in town and told her
mother's
household about these
things Rebecca had a brother his name
was lean and leban ran out to the man to
the spring when he saw the ring now
watch you see how stupid this religion
is to do this to our Bible and the
bracelets on her sister's arms and when
he heard the words of Rebecca's sister
thus the man spoke to me he went to the
man and behold he was standing by the
camels at the spring he said come in oh
blessed of Yahweh why do you stand
outside for I have prepared the house
and a place for the camels so the man
came into the house and Leon ured the
camels and gave him straw
and provender for the camels and water
to wash his feet and the feet of the men
who are with him then food was set
before him to eat but he said I will not
eat until I have told my
Aaron okay now watch just reading it
it's a long section but again this is
what they force us to do to destroy this
Blasphemous nonsense okay now watch
here okay watch
here all right man she's one powerful
three-year-old man I'm hey man do you
guys have any three-year-olds are this
powerful that makes Samson blush even
Arnold Schwarzenegger would be afraid to
enter into competition with this
three-year-old if Arnold Schwarzenegger
had seen her he would say I ain't coming
back you know he says I'll be back I
ain't coming back y yeah whatever you
taking I'm doing the Scarface version of
Arnold schwarzeneger y I'll be back what
are you thaning man
okay all right
so he said I am Abraham's servant the
Lord yahwah has greatly blessed my
master and he has become great he has
given him flocks and herds silver and
gold men's servants and Maid servants
camels and
asses okay see when I call you an ass
don't be upset it's in the Bible you
dumbass see asses and Sarah my Master's
wife bore a son to my master when she
was old and to him he has given all that
he has my master made me swear saying
you shall not take a
wife for my son from the daughters of
the Canaanites in whose land I dwell but
you shall go to my father's house and to
my Kindred and take a wife for my son I
said to my master perhaps the woman will
not follow me woman huh not little girl
woman but you know three-year-olds are
women at that time you guys understand
the culture if you're three-y old woman
but he said to me the Lord yahwah before
my I walk will send his Angel there's
Jesus again the messenger of the father
with you and prosper your way and you
shall take a wife for my son for my
Kindred for my father's
house then you will be free from my oath
when you come to my Kindred and if they
will not give her to you you will be
free from my oath now watch watch here
yeah like uh truth said Powerpuff
Supergirl
right powerful even Superman would run
from
her what Samson dude forget about Samson
you guys thought Samson was amazing
Rebecca's mind-blowing a
three-year-old carrying a water jar by
herself and drawing
water from a spring by herself and then
draws enough water for a flock of camels
which takes about 20 gallons for a c be
satisfied by herself and on top of that
she then run runs back to her home dude
I was thinking Samson was amazing she
put Samson to shame
homie what Samson
man Rebecca stop talking about Samson
talk about Rebecca now watch I came
today to the spring and said oh Lord
yahwah the god of my master Abraham if
now thou will prosper the way which I go
behold I'm standing by the spring of
water let the young woman young woman
woman so she's not a toddler but she's a
young woman meaning she's mature enough
a woman mature enough to have sex
because that's what the word Alma means
to him I shall say pray give me a little
water from your jar to drink and who
will say to me drink and I'll jaw for
your camels Also let her be the woman
whom the Lord has appointed for my
master son see it's ridiculous right but
we got to do this so we got 20 more
verses sorry but this is what the
Muslims do to us we got to read so that
Christians don't fall for this stupid
nonsense right to think the level they
would stoop to to try to justify what a
54y old man did by having sex and
deflowering and demoralizing a
nine-year-old Minor by appealing to
scriptures and distorting what they say
okay no shame no dignity before I had
done speaking in my heart behold Rebecca
came out with her water jar on her
shoulder and she went down to the spring
and Drew so notice what a good brother
brother a good brother lets a
three-year-old go out by herself with
other women to draw water instead of him
who's a mature man young man going out
and doing it this is child abuse this is
child neglect where is DCFS when you
need them hey is it DCFS I don't know
you see what they're doing the brother's
sending out a three-year-old to go draw
water he needs to be thrown in jail that
young girl needs to be protected where
are you CFS how you letting this man do
that to his young three-year-old
sister stupid
right okay let's
continue and she went down and Drew and
I said to her pray let me drink she
quickly let down her jar from her
shoulder and said drink and I'll give
your camels drink also so I drank and
she gave the camels drink also then I
asked her whose daughter are you dude
she's a three-year-old what the hell's
wrong with you why you talk a
three-year-old and having a
three-year-old you know give water to
your camels she
said the daughter of son to him so I put
the ring on her nose and the bracelets
on her arms that's the doy then I bowed
my head and worshiped the Lord and
blessed the Lord the god of my master
Abraham who let me by the right way to
take the daughter of my Master's Kinsman
for a son now then if you'll deal
loyally and truly with my master tell me
and if not and if not you know if you're
not going to give it to me tell me that
I may turn to the right hand or to the
left now almost done guys and we're now
watch
here here it is what it says sorry guys
it's just reading don't get bored you
need to learn this then answered the
thing comes from the Lord yahwah we
cannot speak to you bad or good behold
Rebecca is before you take her and go
and let her be the wife of your master's
son as the Lord has
spoken now it's going to get good so
let's break it down when Abraham's
servant heard these their words he bowed
himself to the Earth before the Lord
yahwah and the servant brought forth
jewelry of silver and of gold and rment
and gave them to
Rebecca he also gave to her brother and
to her mother cost the ornaments this is
the do Mahar that they
give and he and the men who were with
him ate and drank and they spent the
night there when they arose in the
morning he said send me back to my
master her brother and her mother said
let the maiden remain with us a while at
least 10 days after that she may go so
they're trying to
delay her leaving because once she goes
there is no internet there is no
FaceTime they may not see her for years
that's it their daughter's gone they may
not see her again but he said to themo
not delay me since the Lord yahwah has
prospered my way let me go that that I
may go to my master they said we will
call the maiden and ask her so we're
going to ask her we're going to ask a
three-year-old now cuz she's super girl
Powerpuff girl right here you go almost
done I hope you're learning guys how to
destroy these blasphemies
okay watch
here and they called Rebecca and said to
her will you go with this man you
three-year-old you understand you're
three but you have abilities that are
Beyond this world because you came from
a planet called Krypton and you have a
cousin named Kalel and Kalel is in
another planet in another dimension but
one day you little three-year-old you
will grow up and you will meet your
cousin Kalel so three-year-old you have
Mighty Powers you're able to carry a jar
on your shoulder three-year old and draw
water from a spring three-year-old and
you're able to satisfy a flock of camels
with enough water three-year-old and on
top of that you're able to run back home
so you are an amazing three-year-old you
know you're not normal you're
Supernatural three-year-old so as a
three-year-old you understand what we're
saying so three-year-old are you ready
to go and be another man's wife at three
three-year-old okay
okay will you go with this man she said
I will go so they sent away Rebecca
their sister and her nurse right oh she
has a nurse wet nurse no it means even
even in the Islamic sources you'll see
that there are women who are in their
teenageers and they still have a nurse
that has been with them accompanying
them even unto maidenhood okay and
Abraham's servant and his
men and they blessed Rebecca and said to
all sister be the mother of thousands of
10,000 see didn't we tell you you're
Supernatural you three-year-old you're
no ordinary three-year-old you're so
amazing you're gonna have thousands of
kids popping out of your womb because
you are
Supernatural the only thing you need to
be careful of is Kryptonite but as long
as you stand before the Red Sun you will
have the Vitality to have tens of
thousands of children with one shot
Isaac when he consummates marriage one
shot and you're going to be popping
thousands oh you amazing three-year-old
[Music]
you who is that elazer that's Isaac up
up and away and she flies Scoops up
Isaac oh yes I'm an amazing
three-year-old I am
Supergirl and my cousin is c one day he
will come looking for you but don't
worry because as a three-year-old I have
the power to save you just now let's
consumate marriage because I'm about to
pop up thousands of
children in the name of Allah and his
messenger yeah I'm convinced I'm ready
to become Muslim take Shada okay tens of
thousand may your descendants possess
the Gate of those who hate them then
Rebecca and her Maids her Maids plural
arose so she had servants serving her
and rode upon the camels and followed
the men thus the servant took Rebecca
and went his way now watch here final
part we're done and she's one amazing
three-year-old dude
damn watch your man dude where'd you
come
[Music]
from now Isaac had come from beer laahi
Roy and was dwelling in the neab
and Isaac went out to meditate in the
field in evening and he lifted up his
eyes and looked and behold there were
camels
coming and Rebecca lifted up her eyes
and when she saw Isaac this
three-year-old saw with her
supervision elazar yes I see a man at a
great distance how don't you know I have
super vision and I have X-ray vision too
you know bionic man I'm Bionic Woman
look up in the the guy it's camels no
it's conies no it's hyenas no it's
Supergirl all right Rebecca lifted up
her eyes and when she saw Isaac she
alighted from the camel see she flew up
off the camel and said to the servant
who is the man Yonder walking the field
to meet us all
right the servant said it is my master
so she took her veil and covered
herself so she covered herself like a
ninja now watch the Muslims use that you
see this is Islam they practice Islam
see Rebeca wore the hijab she wore the
nikab see Allah they prayed like Muslims
and the woman wore the veil like Muslims
Allah
Allah finally and the servant told Isaac
and all the things that he had done then
Isaac brought her into the tent and took
Rebecca and she became his wife and he
loved her so Isaac was comforted after
his mother's death all right so that's
it so now are you guys convinced Rebecca
was three years old she was a muslima
who wore the hijab the veil and she was
like Solomon's genies and like Solomon's
magic carpent was Solomon would fly on
the winds and some Trad I say even on a
Magic Carpet who had Genies working for
him right and when one Genie even stole
his ring and got him deposed from his
kingdom and sat on his throne pretending
to be Solomon and then slept with
Solomon's wives is all an Islamic
tradition or like Muhammad saying that
Satan stays in the upper part of your
nose and you need to flush Satan by
snorting water in out of nose three
times a day three times in the morning s
water in and out of your nose three
times so you can flush Satan out of your
nose who stays there in the upper part
of your nose this is barari or like when
Muhammad said that Satan would piss in a
person's ear he'd actually piss in the
ears of people so they wouldn't hear the
call of Adan or Muhammad said that when
there's a call to prayer aan Satan
releases a loud fart he farts so loud he
farts so loud so he won't hear the call
of prayer and takes off so too in this
Islamic fairy tale in Islamic
Wonderland Rebecca was three who had
super strength maybe it was her genene
he was helping her x-ray vision and she
wore a veil like a good muslima there
there you
go now can we put this nonsense to rest
anyone reading Genesis 24 can see she
was a mature Maiden emotionally
psychologically physically mature
because she's performing duties that no
threey three-year-old can do can you
point to me to a to a three-year-old who
can take a water jug go to a spring fill
it up and bring it back home can you
point to me to a three-year-old who can
then fill up a water jug a jar and then
give enough water for a flock of camels
at the age of
three is now can we stop the nonsense
when a Muslim brings it up just block
him throw him out because this man has
no honor no Integrity no
shame is that clear now